[Música]
[Aplausos]
inquieta de la gente
raras
así es como la mayoría de mis amigos yo
creo que me pueden describir
y a pesar de todo esto
si estoy en escolta que para los que no
saben son para los alumnos con mejor
promedio de un grado
si no pudieron creer esto que les acaba
de decir están igual que una maestra
en su clase tuvimos un ensayo descartar
hijo dónde está pues algunos alumnos de
la clase se están en la escuela donde
está fernanda este en escolta fernando
no creo que yo fuera parte de este grupo
para los que tenemos el mejor promedio
de un grado porque solo se quedó con una
parte pues de mí y digo no está mal
porque de verdad de hecho un poquito de
relajo en su clase
ella tuvo una percepción que sólo
reflejaba una parte de mí y esta
percepción es igual a la que tienen
todos mis amigos o compañeros o yo no
tengo tampoco una percepción que es
igual a la de todos mis compañeros de
ella
pero tal vez tuviste
cuanto menos de actitud no como yo y
unas amigas en una competencia fuimos a
una para acabar algo primero que nada a
mí me encantan los deportes más que nada
me encanta nadar y también me encanta el
sentimiento de ganar
bueno fuimos a una competencia de
natación en veracruz dos amigas y yo
entonces lo que nosotros no sabíamos al
llegar a esa competencia es que la
categoría era 11 y mayores o sea yo de
11 pequeñita flaquita con una de 15
entonces mis amigas y yo como que no
creímos que les volvamos a ganar de un
principio pero yo a después en lugar de
hacerme más chiquita de lo que ya estoy
me dije a mí misma la competencia no es
contra ellas es contra ti tú vienes a
ser lo que sabes hacer lo que ya hiciste
desde un principio y en algunos hits les
gané y también a mí me gusta mucho esta
frase
el día que tu actitud esté por encima de
tus habilidades lo imposible será
posible para mí esto refleja mucho pero
además de todo también si tú dejas el
corazón en una competencia y se nota
también te percibirán como una persona
ganadora una persona echada para
adelante una persona diferente
bueno aquí la cosa está como hacemos
para que nos vean como realmente somos y
no sólo vean una parte de eso nada
si yo llegara alguna vez al salón
calladita pues con a lo mejor un libro
en la mano probablemente la percepción
de mis compañeros o de mi maestro
cambiaría pero realmente no podría yo
hacer esto por mucho tiempo y sería ya
manipulando la percepción que tienen en
mí no sería yo realmente
el año antepasado en quinto de primaria
entró una maestra a mediados del año
yo sentía que se le atraía pero si muy
muy muy muy muy muy feo contra mí
y una vez me separado de mis amigas
y todo el mundo todos y cada uno estaban
hablando y me separan a mí y me enojé
muchísimo y no me acuerdo cómo le falta
el respeto
y es que no les quiere decir pero
verdaderamente no me acuerdo
mis papás me dijeron fernanda tienes que
ir a arreglar esto con tu maestra no
puede ser que después peleada con tu
maestra por lo que resta del año
fui tomé todas las agallas que tenía y
me disculpé la percepción de las dos
cambios
esto quiere decir que la percepción es
objetiva ya que se adquiere mediante los
sentidos son las sensaciones o
impresiones que nos causan las personas
las cosas las situaciones que nos rodean
los humanos vemos lo que sentimos esto
que decir que vemos lo que queremos ver
y no realmente lo que hay que no es un
problema porque es parte de la raza
humana
esta percepción también la podemos
cambiar o manipular mediante nuestras
acciones nuestra vestimenta nuestros
gestos nuestra actitud
pero no solo en la escuela también en
los deportes y en todo lo que realizas
porque para mí también hay tres cosas
importantísimas para ser buena en un
deporte o para ser un ganador primero
que nada son las aptitudes que se van
mejorando conforme un entrenamiento
segundo es el entrenamiento y la
preparación tanto física como
mentalmente que lo vas mejorando antes
del evento que tengas algo así y para mí
lo más importante y tercero y creo que
para todos aquí son la actitud la
actitud se elige tú puedes tener una
buena o una mala actitud también yo no
estoy diciendo que si tú tienes una
buena actitud que si te preparas que si
tienes todo vas a ganar porque a veces
hay días malos a veces hay días buenos y
también si pierdes
en actitud cuando mucho porque te tienes
que si te tiran te tienes que levantar
una o mil veces y para mí la actitud se
elige se transmite y se percibe así que
se puede decir que la actitud y las
percepciones hermanas y aquí volvemos
una pregunta que hice más atrás en la
plática cómo hacemos para que nos vean
como realmente somos y no sólo habían
una parte de eso nada quisiera darles la
clave para que puedan contestar esto
pero realmente
todos pensamos diferente percibimos
diferentes sentimos diferentes en fin
todos todos y cada uno de ustedes y yo
somos muy diferentes
de manera de hacer que todo el mundo a
todos y cada unas piensan de la misma
manera de mí
la percepción cambia depende de la
persona así que lo mejor que podemos
hacer es pincha to be roja sala el mundo
y con la mejor actitud dejémonos ver
como nosotros mismos que de hecho es la
mejor manera en la que nos podemos
percibir gracias fue todo
[Aplausos]